we are taking our show to the Apollo
Theater in week that's a you know what
do you have some advice do you have some
advice for us first thing you do Kona is
get yourself right
a vocal coach and you learn a gospel
song I'm telling you a good song about
God we're gonna save your life I promise
you you want me to start every show by
going out there and seeing a song about
how I love God
Coenen if you don't want to show ass
booed you better sing about God I
promise you they don't boo God they
never boo God today boot they boo people
at the heart at the Apollo Theater in
Harlem they boo them if they don't like
the act you won't get boo
you will get boo if you only think about
God okay you got a pair of timberlands
so what timberlands mm boots yeah sure
put some timberland boots on and sing
about God music that's more folky right
there you only need some more
inspirational yeah no matter how high I
get I'll still keep looking up to you
just my dad keep your eye on the sparrow
yeah yeah how should I dress you dress
yeah this is this kind of thing okay let
the Apollo no no no no no you want to
button your shirt down to your navel at
least but neither unbutton it unbutton
it though you know one wants to see that
- [ __ ] you button up to the side you
button up to your neighbor not to here
and down to your navel and this is just
very skin yeah I'll tell you and don't
Conan do not do not do that nipple thing
do not do the nipple thing
[Applause]
don't do it a nipple thing don't do it
don't I'm telling you don't do it you
will get booed okay God or not you will
get booed okay
so hands off my own nipples : God yeah
do that
get a shirt up open down to the middle
right here yeah right and don't don't
get a car service there be all bougie
you walk down 125th Street you walk
right I can do that what and walk down
125th Street yeah how do you walk I'll
show you hell no cold oh so how you want
that 125th Street give me a little walk
that 120 pitches
[Applause]
[Music]
see yeah I got it that way you won't be
so ass whoops okay right what'd I do
wrong you're not acknowledging people
around you you pull the petal just twice
and say holla back like this I'll holla
back
holla back see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no one's recognizing me or acknowledging
me yeah what if they just think he's
having heart trouble yeah that's it no
that's what
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
great let's take a break we got love
where it's not about Lauren
you